las sirenas de alerta anti bombardeo
sonaron en jerusalén por primera vez
desde 2014 y no era un simulacro
mientras ciudad vieja y sus alrededores
seguían registrando disturbios desde la
franja de cazas se lanzaron hasta 150
proyectiles según el ejército israelí
esta tarde en el día de jerusalén las
organizaciones terroristas de gaza han
cruzado una línea roja y nos han atacado
con cohetes en las afueras de jerusalén
israel responderá con fuerza como las
fuerzas israelíes respondieron con una
ola de ataques sobre la franja de gaza
entre los fallecidos hay menores de edad
como puede ser esto culpa de los niños
niñas de entre 7 y 9 años han muerto
como puede ser su culpa estábamos
sentados fuera de la casa esperando la
oración la violencia que se está
viviendo en la región ha provocado
protestas en distintos países como
marruecos o jordania y reacciones
internacionales que piden el fin de los
enfrentamientos
enfoques
estamos muy centrados en la situación de
israel cisjordania y gaza muy
preocupados por los ataques con cohetes
que hemos visto y que deben cesar y
deben cesar inmediatamente
los choques activos desde el viernes se
han visto avivados por los intentos de
desahucio de familias palestinas en
jerusalén con cientos de nuevos heridos
durante la jornada la atención también
se extiende a las zonas árabes del norte
del país y a cisjordania